[Music]
you guys remember that last year young
dude made a trailer
uh called bel-air it was like a dramatic
reimagining
of the fresh prince of bel air and i'm
about to talk to him right now
there's big news stay tuned
my guys my guys
we have just officially
closed the deal with peacock
with an unprecedented
two season order from a pitch
i've been in this business for 30 years
and
that does not happen they ordered
two full seasons of bel air
based on the quality of the pitch and
the work that you guys
have done so i want to say
congratulations
i am hyped thank you that's so exciting
morgan it's a testament to your vision a
two-season commitment
is just yeah nothing says we believe in
the show
uh yeah he's in commitment now it's on
you
you guys back i happily carry that on
the one hand it's so personal to you and
your journey
as an artist and here we are sharing
that with you right now
and uh that's you know
that's enormous and then and then
tapping into what's happening
around us right now yeah yes instead
getting us
back to humanity that's what i'm most
excited about and what really
um really clicked in my mind
about the when i saw the trailer that
morgan did
the concepts in the fresh prince of
bel-air
re-imagined as a drama like
you know a real kid from west
philadelphia
modern day a black family
bel air the the carlton character
a black young republican
modern day like that like the
heat that would be stirred up between
these characters
it's like what's the hillary character
in a world of instagram and social media
i'm so glad you're here i need to take
you shopping rodeo drive
oh my gosh like what does that become
uncle phil a black lawyer turned
judge today with you know young black
kids coming before
him i'm the law and viv
a a professional woman that decided to
raise her family and now that her kids
are older making her way back into
the the world of of what is her life
going to be
as her kids have grown up you know like
all of that stuff is
so rich dude yes there's so many layers
to these characters you know what i mean
and we're really going to peel back the
layers of these iconic characters and
explore this world in a really
unforgettable way you know it's a show
that's really going to surprise people
in the best way possible morgan you were
you're a cinematographer
from from kc from kansas city so you
kind of
grew up with the fresh prince and then
where'd you get the
the idea to
shoot shoot a trailer it's crazy man i
was driving on 71 in kansas city
missouri my hometown and uh
you know i was just thinking about the
show and it's a show that we all grew up
with all 90s kids
it's a part of our life and man listen i
drove under this overpass
okay when i came out from one of that
overpass
the the entire world just hit me all at
once that's crazy
in this moment man the vision just
became so clear and i said
i have to make this you know it's an
idea that came straight from the heart
you know i've always been manifesting
things into existence
and the vision came to me i knew
something i had to create no matter what
and two years later you know to be
walking in this journey together with
you and chris is not only a dream come
true but it's something
that i really honestly feel was was
destined you know and a big shout out to
the entire bel air trailer team
you know we made history together and
it's only the beginning well i
i am uh excited
and i am uh here to
uh be as involved or as
all the way out your way as you guys uh
uh need me to be we got two seasons
at the the peacock congratulations
um now the hard work begins
so congrats i appreciate you guys
excellent one quick question yes
if you could uh you know go back in time
right now
and you know you're in vanities on the
pilot
of the freshman seven you can go back
you learned over the years and talk to
that young man what would you say
you know i think um
yeah i've thought about that a a a few
times
and at that point in my life
i was as wildly
fearless and create as creative as
i have ever been i would
say or do anything
it's it's almost like i would ask that
guy for advice
wow that's beautiful right
he knew something like at that age
there there's a there's a certain power
in naivete
right when you really don't know
and you're not scared
it's like i didn't realize that was a
network
television show and you can't
just change lines
like you can't just sing a song
that's a popular song on a show
they now they got to pay for it if you
do that like
there was so many rules um in terms of
comedy i would like i was so free with
my body i didn't care how i
looked i didn't care like there was a
there was a
level of reckless abandon
that i've been dying to try to find
again over the last like four or five
years of my life
that's so beautiful thank you for
sharing that yeah all right
appreciate it let's go get it thank you
two
seasons i'll holla at y'all in a minute
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
you